un versailles efficace ce dimanche 11
mars dans leur stade de porchefontaine
les joueurs de la cité royale troisième
de division honneur longtemps portées
contre le 5e clairement avec à la clé
six s inscrire le point de bonus
offensif score final 39 à 8 soit match
de reprise on a voulu déjà gagné ce
match ça s'est fait avec le bonus logo
n'est content on restera voilà sur cinq
matches avec bonus offensif formé à 30 à
40 points de moyenne sur les cinq
derniers matches mais au-delà du
résultat la prestation collective dé
versailles et sur cette rencontre n'a
pas été séduisante aux yeux du stuff
conseillère match de reprise on a pas de
rythme c'est normal d'accord il faut
bosser la circulation offensive
l'utilisation du ballon latitude dans
les contacts ont été pointés du doigt
par l'entraîneur historique nous fait
donc voilà on a pas on a eu du mal à
enchaîner 3 4 temps de jeu et à mettre
du rythme dans le match et puis on est
tombé dans une bouillie de rugby en
faisant trop de fautes quoi trop de
fautes de main des mauvais placements se
retrouve à dire voilà il besoin de
retravailler
même les supporters en bas du strict
elle est forcément aujourd'hui on veut
vraiment réussir à marquer des choses en
place d'ici la fin de saison chances que
ça passe par de la rigueur est fou et là
je coache un peu dur mais c'est c'est
normal puisqu'on est capable de produits
proposés puisqu'on a proposé aujourd'hui
je pense que l'on pouvait beaucoup mieux
faire pour corriger ces approximations
les versailles ont rendez vous ce
dimanche 18 mars à 15 heures ils
affronteront chevreuse pour le derby
noix de ce championnat honneur